okay guys this video is not sponsored by
chucky cheese I'm making this video
purely because I want to get to the
bottom of this shane dawson chucky
cheese pizza conspiracy theory
so shane dawson recently released a
conspiracy sevilla that has over 17
million views in two days
in that video he investigates a theory
about chucky cheese and he sort of
concludes that they're taking leftover
pizza and making new pies out of it the
only problem is that he never actually
confirms it a lot of people are freaking
out about it but i don't believe it just
yet i have a lot of questions it doesn't
make sense to me first of all i don't
know why a business would take leftover
pizza when they can just make another
one for a low cost also I've been
reading online a lot of ex employees
have been denying these accusations
why would somebody work that chucky
cheese ten years ago wanna lie about
this oh so I used to love chucky cheese
as a kid so I don't want to believe this
just yet I want actual proof now I'm not
a journalist but I think that it's
common practice if you're putting out a
story about a company or a person you
need to reach out to that company for a
statement
BuzzFeed News did an article about this
Shane Dawson video and when they reached
out to Chucky Cheese the representative
said no conspiracies here our pizzas are
made to order and we prepare our dough
fresh in restaurant which means that
they're not always perfectly uniform in
shape but always delicious I'm gonna
reach out to Chucky Cheese and see if
they can prove that to me and show me
how they actually make their pizza okay
so I just got off the phone with Chuck E
Cheese it is 7:00 a.m. right now I'm
gonna go to Chuck E Cheese I'm meeting
them at 9:00 a.m. and they're gonna take
me to their kitchen and show me exactly
how they make the pizza okay we're at
the Chucky Cheese I'm pretty excited to
just go in cuz I haven't been in a
Chucky Cheese in like maybe 1718 years I
don't I don't you remember what Chuck
cheese looks like my face now I'm gonna
go in
we like representative he's gonna show
me exactly the other pizzas made so
let's do it
two doors are locked never mind we're
not doing this video you'll be meeting
with he's not here yet but you can just
come in and make yourself oh cool thanks
awesome I got a whole chucky cheese to
myself
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
okay got a little distracted I'm out of
breath but Mike is here so let's go do
this interview let's get to the bottom
of this figure out exactly how the
pizzas made have you seen the Shane
Dawson video I'm really proud of our
pizza but you you seen it how is it kind
of affected you guys is there some sort
of effect it's just like a joke our
pizzas aren't cookie cutter pizzas yeah
they're not frozen pizzas we don't peel
plastic off of our pizzas and throw them
in an oven so they're not gonna be
perfect
yeah every pizza is hand stretched every
piece is hand done so I guess what
you're saying is that the conspiracy
theory is false it is just a theory
absolutely false okay so unequivocably
false there is no way so does the pizza
making process explain kind of like why
the shape is the way absolutely can you
take me through the picture absolutely
so our dough starts as a bag of flour
and water we get 80 degree waters well
we start all of our dough apps one part
water to two parts down we add our dough
mixture we mix it for 12 minutes then
we're gonna take that dough and we form
it into individual balls based on sizes
then that fun gets cheated out into an
actual skin itself that doesn't happen
for the whole other day so the pizza
that you're starting today actually
started yesterday when we pull a skin
out of the pan itself and put it onto
the screen then it's gonna be cooked on
it doesn't necessarily fit all the time
sometimes it's gonna come to the edge of
the screen sometimes it hangs over the
edge of the screen I don't want it to
look perfect I'm okay with a little bit
of way than a little bit of difference
there then we're gonna take the sauce or
[ __ ] out the right amount of sauce and
we have the cheese on we're gonna do
everything based on a chart we do our
pepperonis based on count sometimes
they're folded over a little bit our
pizzas all done so then we're gonna take
and we place it onto the conveyor of our
oven so our ovens are conveyor ovens but
they're called impinge or ovens so the
heat source is actually in the back of
the oven itself it's super heats air and
we use as big fans to blow the air out
over the top
to the top of the pizza and the bottom
of the pizza itself that's really
important right because if we were to
ever reheat anything we can't because of
health code if we reheated anything that
hot air on the top it all it's gonna do
with bird and you guys have no
microwaves you can't find a microwave in
any chuck-e-cheese sketches so we're
gonna take our pizza out of the oven by
using our tongues and our spatula to
take it out of the oven itself we have a
pizza chart up at the top that it shows
what our standard cut amounts would be
for a large it's 12 slices extra large
of 16 slices but when I'm in the heat of
the moment and I've got 50 pizzas coming
out of that oven and I'm cutting through
using that rocker knife from top from
the front to the back
sometimes those pieces are gonna be a
little uneven I'm not getting a
protractor in there to try and cut those
pieces and make sure that they're at a
perfect 22 degree angle for every single
slice that's coming up on time for that
and then when you guys transfer it
there's a kind of shift that's the key
right that's the moment so we're putting
them on to these cool touch trays a lot
of places like you go to a to-go box and
they'll slide it into the to-go box hole
and then cut it in the to-go box that's
not how we do it we cut it on our actual
pizza peel itself cut it through and
then transfer it onto that board
well that process that motion is gonna
move some stuff around stuffs gonna
jostle so some of those pieces are gonna
slide up and some of those pieces are
gonna slide back down as a convenience
we take a plastic knife and we slide it
underneath one of the slices of pizza to
make a nice and easy as that slice gets
picked up it's gonna move that around a
little bit it might move some of the
adjacent slices next to it Justin we can
use that to help carry the pizza to the
table as well and Shane was also talking
about like how some of the pizzas the
slices looked like they were glued
together with cheese basically why does
that look happen so our cheese is a
hundred percent mozzarella cheese so
there's no starches there's no binders
there's no any kind of other chemicals
it is literally milk that's assets it's
just cheese that cheese is still at its
melting point at that point when we pull
it out of that 500 degree oven that
cheese is still above its melting point
so if I choose and I cut it and move it
around that ste that cheese still has
the ability to melt
one of the things Shane mentioned in
this video was the pepperoni slices is
there an explanation for that yes if we
pull up the actual slice itself you'll
see that pepperonis kind of slid down
onto the side it's still the whole thing
it just happens to be there that's just
the way it gets cut all right so now I
know the entire process we made the
pizza together can we taste testing
because ultimately all that matters is
how it tastes
darn right I love our keys let's try
some pizza thank you for doing all this
today this is like our little little
pizza date now absolutely my pleasure
this is genuinely a good pizza and I
live in New York this is really good I'm
gonna bring it back to the office or
have a bunch of tasty producers have a
bunch of my friends taste it just make
sure everyone likes it awesome
but dude thank you hey thanks for coming
this is incredible any time put it back
I would be the crapper some oregano here
your guys they're giving you seasonings
[Music]
you